على طريق موحل محاط بضفة من
الأشجار الطويلة والفروع، توجد
مزرعة قديمة تركها أصحابها منذ بعض الوقت
ولكن لديها مكان
إقامة جديد، هؤلاء جنود من
اللواء الميكانيكي 47 حيث نحتفظ
بصواريخنا وهم جزء من القتال
بالنسبة لأبيفا، واحدة من أكثر
المعارك ضراوة على الجبهة الشرقية لأوكرانيا،
مموهة تحت الغابة، عبارة عن
نظام إطلاق صاروخي متعدد
من الحقبة السوفيتية
حيث تنطلق نيران المدفعية من
الحقول القريبة، ويتمنى ساشا البالغ من العمر 32 عامًا أن
يكون لديهم أسلحة أفضل وأكثر حداثة.
عندما تضرب
بالأسلحة الحديثة والأسلحة الغربية
بالطبع، فهي أكثر دقة
وتتسبب، على سبيل المثال، في إلحاق المزيد من الضرر بالعدو
في الشهرين الماضيين، وكانت روسيا
ترسل موجات وموجات من القوات
إلى هناك  إنهم يحاولون تطويق
المدينة لكن ساشا وزملائه الجنود
يعلمون أن هذه الحرب يمكن أن تصبح أكثر
صعوبة إذا جفت المساعدات الأمريكية المعرضة للتهديد الآن
فجأة،
وإذا لم يوافق الكونجرس الأمريكي على حزمة المساعدات العسكرية، فلن
تحصل أوكرانيا على الأسلحة المتقدمة التي
تحتاجها بشدة.  لخوض هذه الحرب،
وهذا يعني أنه سيتعين عليها الاعتماد بشكل أكبر
على المعدات السوفيتية القديمة منذ عقود
مثل
هذه الخريجة لمحاربة القوات الروسية التي
تكتسب التفوق على خط المواجهة،
وأخشى أن أوكرانيا لن تكون قادرة على
الوقوف بدون شركائنا وحلفائنا  لذا فإن
الأمر بهذه البساطة،
فالأمر الأثقل على
أذهانهم هو الإعدام المزعوم الأسبوع الماضي
لجنديين أوكرانيين غير مسلحين
كانا يستسلمان للقوات الروسية على مسافة ليست
بعيدة عن
موقع ساشا، وتُظهر لقطات الطائرات بدون طيار أعضاء الحزب الاشتراكي وهم
يتسلقون من أذرعهم المخبأة فوق
رؤوسهم قبل ذلك.  إطلاق النار من
مسافة قريبة تحقق أوكرانيا الآن فيما
يسميه المدعي العام انتهاكًا صارخًا
لاتفاقيات جنيف، وكل حدث مماثل يجلب
لنا الكثير من الألم والمعاناة، وهذا
بالتأكيد لن يجعلنا ضعفاء،
ولن يخيفنا، سنستمر  إننا نفعل
ما يتعين علينا
القيام به وهو خوض حرب لا نهاية لها على ما يبدو
حيث يقومون ببناء المزيد من الخنادق
غير المؤكد ما إذا كان الغرب سيبقى
هناك حقًا على المدى الطويل إذا سمحنا
لأوكرانيا بالرحيل إذا سمحنا لبوتين بالفوز فمن
سيشعر بالأمان
هنا أعتقد لا
واحد